hey Alex I heard you have a question for
me so on his channel
yeah he's applying science to ordinary
foods in ways that he's trying to
improve it
Hey Dude what's up my name is Alex I'm a
youtuber and I make videos about a food
but from DIY and science a point of view
so my last video was about pan seasoning
you know the most common and historical
method to season depends to burn fat
inside it in order to create a dry heart
and kind of nonstick surface so
allegedly oil polymerization is
responsible for that now I am wondering
why does that coating stick to the
material to the metal in my case carbon
steel or even cast iron and I'm also
wondering how could we make that bond
stronger also I know my question is
chemistry related and that you are on
that astrophysicist so just imagine that
you're seasoning in space thank you
that's pretty funny Wow just the way he
speaks I wanted to be my chef and
without it down the food will be bad no
matter what he's written exactly it's or
flakes it's gonna be French corn flakes
you can't cook at all it's just like he
just tells you it's good you're like oh
my god it's all better exactly I have
CDs with my words sorry that's the
American mentality manifested there so
first of all the oil that makes the
surface of the pan nonstick which by the
way is the secret of well-seasoned walks
mmm okay you can iron wok has oil has
been on there multiple times so the oil
is now the surface of the pan and it's
smooth because the pan itself the
metallic surface is structured okay so
you put in oil and oil will fill all the
nooks and crannies and make a smooth
surface and then you burn it there okay
so then it just solidifies the part that
got burned the polymerization is what
he's talking about
right but what my point is be
that it's stuck because it's burned onto
the pan you can remove it with a brillo
pad or with heavy soap you can remove it
it's not permanently affixed the way
Teflon is sort of permanently attached
basically right you know you can take a
belt sander and remove it but otherwise
the Teflon is on so it's not permanently
attached it's there and you have to be
careful to not remove it when it's time
to wash it so so no it's not permanently
attached why it's nonstick that's a
really really smooth surface at that
point and not all smooth surfaces are
nonstick so I don't have a good answer
for that
okay I'll plead ignorance on this but
what I did see recently is the frontier
of nonstick surfaces they're putting it
on the inside of a ketchup bottle that
makes sense so you tip the cutter and it
just slides out they put you tipped the
mayonnaise bottle and it just slides out
okay that sounds manually manage the
frontier of nonstick surfaces when
introduced to food means there's much
less food waste right we try to get the
last of the peanut butter in the jar the
last of the mayonnaise the last of
everything else so at home we have a
whole set of tools of I get every little
bit basically squeegees that's what they
are and help get it again at all you
know and I cut to cut it open you know
nature's first squeegee but the tongue
there you go I try not to do it in a
restaurant but at home I'm licking the
plate if the sauce is good I'm licking
the plate my sister tells you that
that's in France supposedly the highest
compliment you can pay is that right pay
a chef is if you take the plate and you
I mean you don't really but it's
basically it's tactfully one-time and
just like that's compliments to the chef
like that's how good it was just like in
some other parts if you burp that's a
great exactly right
and that's that's my Uncle Jim's house
right away
by the way this is great beer so sorry I
only got to half your answer there but
that's the best I can do as an
astrophysicist not it's not so much
chemists but material scientists they're
the ones who think about the surfaces of
of solid objects and how they interact
so you know what he does yeah brings the
methods and tools of science to food nah
he's not the first to do that but he
doesn't in a very fun and interesting
way you see all his failures and you and
you look at the process you look at the
thoughts that went that went into it so
I just think that's great because the
kitchen is the first and last bastion of
science in the household nice at the
chemistry that's right of the food you
add to get it's got the physics of the
heat and thing and it's got the biology
cuz you cooking something that was once
alive that's right no matter if it was a
plant or not correct which is why when I
cut my carrots I here on though my
celery does that from the same garden
[Music]